senators are back in Washington working
on the Republican plan to repeal and
replace Obamacare the president tweeted
this morning I cannot imagine that
Congress would dare to leave Washington
without a beautiful new health care bill
fully approved and ready to go
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell has
worked to try and attract the 50 votes
he needs some Republicans including
Arizona Senator John McCain think the
bill is in trouble my view is it's
probably going to be dead but I am I've
been wrong I thought I'd be President
but I think I think I've fear that it's
gonna fail McCain says working with
Democrats could increase support CBS CBS
News contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for The
Washington Post good morning good to see
you all here all back yeah I mean I did
yeah you guys were here last week we
were here part of the weekend you were
here I saw part of the week yeah let's
talk about Congress and they came back
is it is it possible that they could
leave for the August recess the recess
without getting anything done including
health care yep believe it or not and
that's why the president's tweaked this
morning is quite on point because I
think most Americans would be thinking
this morning how is it possible and if
they could leave without doing it in
fact while they were gone last week on
this July 4th recess a number of these
Republican senators heard from their
constituents and it's making this repeal
and replace even hardly been more
difficult you now have as many as 10
Republican senators saying they've got
issues with it they got concerns they
can't support so they're for how likely
is it that McConnell will turn to the
Democrats well it's becoming
increasingly likely that that could
happen I think we're looking at about
another week's worth of work among
Republicans to try to come up with a
plan they're waiting for the latest
scorekeeping report to come in from the
Congressional Budget Office which might
come about Friday in the meantime he's
got to work with these Republicans to
see if there's any other possible way to
get 50 of them to hold together on a
plan Ted Cruz has some ideas that are
much more conservative that upsets the
moderates and some others in the middle
and and if he can somehow pull a rabbit
out of a hat and make it happen this
week that maybe they're worried about
what it does to pre-existing condition
to pre-existing conditions and
to the marketplace in general but what
McConnell said last week is if we can't
do it we've got to shore up the status
quo and work with Democrats on that and
the Democratic requests then are you
leave Medicaid alone don't do what
you're trying to do to right now and and
you just you know shore up what's there
essentially and try to fix it not
wholesale replace it the Republicans
have a pretty long to-do list at this
point and the polls seem to show that
the American people are blaming Congress
yeah not the president for the problem
of getting this health care that's right
we were just talk about this Gail the
wish list is about to get scratched for
the to-do list because there are so many
things well there's so many things they
have to do before the end of September
in order to keep the government the
country running they got to pass a
budget they're gonna have to sort of
when to raise the debt limit there's a
host of federal programs that have to be
reauthorized like the FAA the National
Flood Insurance Program a veteran's
health care plan needs some money a
children's health insurance program
needs to be reauthorized all that plus
they got to come up with a spending plan
by the end of the fiscal year on
September 30th so all those things eat
up time that plus confirming judges
confirming those under secretaries and
ambassadors and other folks that the
president is confirming and you've only
got three weeks between now and the end
of the month when they take a five-week
break they come back after Labor Day and
they've only got a few things really get
that break this time with a seat on the
table the way they stick around is if
the Senate gets something done on health
care in the next three weeks and the
house goes why wouldn't we stick around
a few extra days to get it done and
deliver the president the health care
Ben Sasse has recommended that yeah Ben
Sasson and several other members of the
House as well president Trump had
promised an infrastructure bill did that
ever show up
no and and having a injured LaGuardia
last night I think myself and many of
them would like to see that happen first
but no and that's and that's the real
disappointment for a lot of people in
Washington is that you know that would
have been a very smart way to start
everyone agrees that the roads the
bridges and godforsaken airports need
help need to be rebuilt need need money
spent on them and they would create jobs
and it guys do one thing most likely to
generate Democratic Club absolutely yes
you know they were ready to go with that
and then we're and are still eager to
work with him on it know both sides say
they want the bill let's see what
happens yes we'll see the clock is
ticking Thank You ed okie it's good to
see it variable